tomorrow night there are more 2020
Democratic primaries and it's do-or-die
for Bernie Sanders now against Joe Biden
did this is it right I mean everybody
else is out of the race or has no chance
the current delegate counts after Super
Tuesday are Joe Biden 664 Bernie Sanders
573 that's a 91 delegate lead for Joe
Biden in tomorrow night's elections
there are a total of 350 two delegates
available this includes Idaho Michigan
Mississippi Missouri Washington and a
caucus in North Dakota and so Bernie
Sanders needs to make up that difference
of 91 and that would require Bernie
getting 222 of the delegates tomorrow
night Biden would get 130 that would tie
them now there's a couple things that we
have to understand as far as that goes
if Bernie wins roughly 2/3 of the
delegates tomorrow and we'll see whether
that's likely in a second if Bernie does
that and ties Biden then we have what's
called the Florida problem on March 17th
Florida votes Florida is a hundreds of
delegates and Joe Biden is reportedly
winning by 50 or more points there
Bernie Sanders did very poorly in
Florida in 2016 so we'll take it one day
at a time and I'll tell you what's going
on but let's start with how likely is it
that Bernie Sanders could make up the
difference
tomorrow night well let's look at the
state-by-state expectations first with
polling in Idaho there is very little
polling and most tracker websites say
Idaho could end up being a tie it's very
few delegates so it won't make much of a
difference but let's call Idaho a tie in
Michigan in the latest polls Biden is
leading by as much as 20 now Bernie is
putting a lot of his eggs in the
Michigan basket but the latest polls
have Biden up 20 in an average of recent
polls Biden's up 9 in Michigan in a
Mississippi Biden is up just a crazy
amount the numbers don't even matter
it's not going to be close in
Mississippi Missouri Biden is up 13
Washington Biden is up 2 that's a
possibility for Bernie and then North
Dakota is a caucus and it
roughly is a tie so if we apply those
numbers to the delegates as we would
expect them tomorrow evening again
currently you have Bernie with 573 and
Biden with 664 if they split the Idaho
Washington and North Dakota delegates
roughly evenly we would expect based on
the polling Biden to build a lead with
Michigan Mississippi and Missouri
delegates and my estimate right now
again if the polling changes by tomorrow
we'll update these numbers my estimate
is that Biden will likely grow his
delegate lead tomorrow night from 91 to
140 this is just the most likely
situation based on the data math and
polling not based on anything other than
that we'll update that tomorrow with the
latest poll numbers we're expecting some
polls to come out today that include
weekend polling in some of these states
that will be voting tomorrow Bernie
Sanders has been spending a lot of time
in Michigan although the latest polls
they're actually worse for him we'll see
if that does anything tonight Bernie has
a town hall on Fox News which I will be
covering live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook starting about 6:00 p.m.
Eastern Time we'll see if that does
anything for Bernie Bernie needs to not
just over perform the polls he needs to
win some of these states by large
margins or at least by a respectable
margin in order to even have a
possibility on March 17th of not falling
irreparably behind again because Florida
a huge state Florida Democrats more
conservative outside of Miami than many
of the the Democrats in some other parts
of the country and that is going to be
an uphill battle we will be covering it
I am just the messenger here remember I
think you're going to want to check this
out for just 19
award-winning antivirus and VPN for an
entire year on three of your devices all
you have to do is go to total AV comm
slash David Pakman total AV antivirus
couldn't be simpler to use you install
it once you forget about it and it keeps
your
Vice safe from viruses spyware
ransomware and adware I use it on all my
devices it works on Windows and Mac
computers works on Android and iOS
phones and tablets you're really
vulnerable if you don't have an added
layer of antivirus protection to guard
you from online threats totally these
trusted antivirus will give you that
peace of mind and like I said as part of
the deal you'll get their premium VPN
which makes you anonymous online it
encrypts your internet activity hides
your IP addresses from websites you
visit there are many advantages to using
a VPN and it's all for 19 bucks you'll
get total Ivy's antivirus software and
their high quality VPN both for an
entire year and you can use them on
three different devices simultaneously
just go to total AV comm slash David
Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video